[Music]
let me start by saying on camera again
how much I loved what I've seen of your
show thank you fantastic spec yeah and
especially and I don't mean him but
myself in here but just because of
there's an abundance of television out
there there's an abundance of movies
we've all seen a million things and I
promise the people that are watching you
will see stuff you've never seen before
on your show probably for a good reason
probably for excellent reasons that no
one has seen that [ __ ] before it right
but we're showing it a hundred percent
so I'm very curious for the four of you
first what was it like reading these
scripts or the read getting involved
reading that pilot script for the first
time and seeing what they're trying to
accomplish with the show it was really
refreshing I think to read it it was
just kind of like like you said there's
nothing else like that in his actors you
know you read so many you know bad
scripts I think when you see something
that's like amazing and original and
like holy [ __ ] I want to be a part of
this you know that was the reaction for
me there's like one line in the screen
direction that sold me like super early
on as I was reading through and I'm not
gonna say exactly what it is or what it
is but I'm gonna say but I'm not gonna
give you all the context I don't wanna
give anything away for people who have
not seen it but it there was a line in
the screen direction that says like we
see this character ping because you just
never [ __ ] see superheroes pee and
it's like it's like page 12 it's like
early oh yeah I read that line and I was
like oh I'm in this is sick I knew then
that was like yeah this is exactly what
I want to be yeah I think there's
elements in that like for all of us I
think all of us felt the same about the
material when we first got it and I
definitely you know the transplant of a
psychopathic Superman is sort of thing I
jumped at it man and there was there's
never a doubt in my mind I wanted to be
a part of it it feels like the headline
for this piece should be all of these
actors in one way or another been
touched by superhero pee
I am I mean the script was so good not
what I expected at all that's what I
loved about it but one thing that also
stood out to me and I remember we
discussed this was that when you when he
writes scripts whole like put in little
gems that just the actors working on the
scripts will read and will know about
like in parentheses like just like
things to like throw out there just for
the sake of like enhancing the content
of the scripts you don't I'm out like in
parentheses you'll be like I don't I
can't even think of an example but you
know what I'm talking about you but like
yes this really is really freaking her
from the boys any an experience
experience just to read it and I was
like all right it's gonna be fun to like
I feel like if you're gonna write a
script like you should make it
entertaining to read so I'm always
putting like little jokes and stuff in
scripts also something that's uncommon
is getting a second season before the
first season even premieres yeah which
is first of all I'm all in on that
second of all I just learned in the
previous interview that you guys are
already filming it where it would deep
into season two brother right that is
again as a fan amazing yeah so it's
gonna be so the first season's episodes
second season is eight episodes you so
where are you in the production process
and when do you wrap because I'm already
trying to do the math as to when I'm
gonna see it it'll come it'll it'll drop
about one full year after the first
season so about the same time next year
it'll come okay basically next comic-con
you'll be back doing like I'm living
correct hopefully filming season three
fingers crossed brother right man okay
so I want to jump into a few just fun
question cuz I know you can't ruin the
show for the four of you who ruins the
most takes and why what who ruins the
most takes and why
between the four of us yeah ruin one the
other night I can't keep a straight face
I can't keep a straight face anything
that's remotely that's if I'm working
with this guy's tough to keep a straight
face what do you mean okay
what he's saying is I suck and so he's
just like Jesus what are you doing so I
think why by proxy what he's saying is I
ruin the most eggs just being there just
being in shock who would you say out of
the entire cast who were ruined the most
stakes an interesting question who blows
the most eggs
I like all four of you were looking like
what is he it's not it's not these guys
I'm trying to like I gotta look at each
one of you well yeah let me look at the
room because those guys I mean yeah yeah
yeah black waters a totally mute
character he blows his life see all over
us uniforms a green matcha tea like did
she did she know she she was always on
her lines but she would often you know
she would she's crafty though she's an
old campaigner right so she if she
doesn't like something she's not happy
where my she'll find a reason that
something's not right and she was just
she takes control of us completely who
of the four of you who always gets it in
one well here's the thing I mean here's
what I think what's hard about these
questions anyway is like you want well
has it takes like getting it in one is
like the least interesting thing because
I I accept that but there's certain
people that like every you know certain
I've spoken a lot of actors and some
actors say that like they're warming up
third fourth take their in it or enemy
and other people say I need to get to
like ten takes and I'm feeling it and
some people it's like game on on the
first take right I know who gets it
the people that get it every single time
in the first take of a guest actors when
we're in overtime you know they're
moving on we do yeah we do like every
setup we do like Kubrick Ian's like
usually it's 45 or 50 takes per setup
because you don't really get to the
truth until you get to take 25 yeah you
know every every every every setup and
we shoot each one is a sixty-day yes
absolutely
there's a lot of TV shows no no in every
up every episode is one hundred and
seventy million dollars right okay I
mean I'm gonna ask actually something so
the first making the first season of any
show you are not only figuring it out
but you're learning the infrastructure
as to what you can do with your budget
what you can do with your eight-day
shoot you're figuring out how to make
the show so I am curious what did you
learn making season one that now you're
taking it to season two that has helped
with the the actual making that's a good
question so the first one wasn't good
but that one was yeah yeah let me
rephrase it finally a good question no
it's um it's like you know it's a it's
with the size of these budgets and and
you know and we have a pretty healthy
budget but still the I always say like
you're starting a multi-million dollar
company from scratch and you really just
do it overnight and so there's a lot of
trial and error to sort of figuring out
not just like what you can do better and
what works better what like what camera
styles work better I think we've gotten
a lot better at like and as good as the
gore is in season one I think we've
gotten a lot better about how to shoot
the gore properly in season two you
think if they not yeah always agree with
ya but also it's like you get to know
because we wrote most of the first
season before we cast anybody so and
best way to write for one of the reasons
I love television is you can tailor the
role to the actor well and it becomes a
very symbiotic thing like you take what
you see the actor doing and you're like
oh that's interesting and start playing
with that and pushing with that and
season - that to me that's the most
exciting part about being able to come
back to do it because now now because we
know who these characters are we can say
and how they play on screen then we can
say ok now we can twist them or
challenge them in ways that you just
couldn't in season one for the four of
you guys oh I'm basically out of time
but I'm gonna sneak this question in
from season one what's like a day
without spoilers please what's a day you
will always remember actually let's go
across down the line what what's a day
you will always remember from filming
the first season with the microphone
they always remember let's see there was
a day when I was shooting with the
Hughie character and his dad it's not a
spoiler to say Simon Pegg is dead of
shooting with those guys and it's a very
strenuous scene for a train that is the
one that I'm referring to and I kind of
just remember like going through hell in
this scene and then I look over at Simon
Pegg and he just has like the kindest
face because he's like off camera I'm
going through [ __ ] I look over at Simon
he's just like myself back in the moment
like I don't know I just love things
like that you know I mean you'll be so
into it and then like something like a
Simon Pegg facial expression just take
you all out of engines emember like oh
yeah we're shooting a show right now
that's great I mean I have so many from
season 1 a few but I probably can't you
know talk yeah well there's one in
particular I'm thinking of but no so
Amazon came up with this thing you know
to do like a promotional thing within
the world of the show and it was
basically the deep you know kind of
doing one of those like celebrity you
know
overseas commercials like ha you know
hawking soy sauce so I had to go to my
trailer and they and they sent over like
a guy who you know helped me with the
Japanese and I mean it was the most
ridiculous you know thing ever it was
really funny I mean it was like it's
supposed to be it's cheesy
you know soy sauce commercial it was
shot in character and that was probably
shouldn't really oh my god you know what
I mean this is this is this is the show
yeah which I love that somewhat a
brilliant like there's a giant octopus
guy in an octopus suit thank you for
your sacrifice you stole mine yeah I did
a commercial as well and they were
hilarious because those are the
commercials do you grew like those are
the commercials I grew up with him when
I was a little girl like I was like when
you do those Neutrogena commercials were
here it's like you frickin made it we
had an ice cream truck on one one day on
set that was pretty great yeah that's
right listen foods the secret to keeping
everyone happy craft service is
everything I realize that for me
I didn't get to do a commercial
unfortunately I'm hoping we get to do in
this year cuz it was funny but you know
what it is we there was such an extent
so there was such an extensive process
making the super suits we were we got so
I got signed on
we all got signed on six months prior to
make these suits and then this psychotic
character that's got this other outward
persona that is you know the people's
hero as Jesus a lot no it's like meeting
Jesus but putting that all together
and then putting it in this suit I think
that probably my favorite day actually
was my first day and it was in the void
the the de Voort hours office but it was
a meeting of the full seven all of the
suits and everything was coming together
at once and I was like and Dan and Eric
were there and it's just you know it's
your first moment like what are you
gonna do and I was like well I gotta be
still I gotta be I gotta be taking in my
world and Dan came up at the same time
what was he you but one of you came up
and and said what do you want said I
think was Dan came up and said he said
what do you think you for the stead of
saying I'm like dude I got to be
standing up here and it was just that
moment that moment of clarity like being
slightly raised up and cuz homeland is
got to be this guy that [ __ ] owns
everything and everyone often and it was
just that moment like everything just
came together and then it all just made
sense and I look at these guys and it
was like wow it's happening I know the
scene you're talking about yeah at all
yeah it is that moment of like clarity
having everyone's worked so hard on the
sits they're amazing and LJ suit
designers like put so much love and care
and detail everyone has the whole team
into these suits and they're to feel it
all just come together and create a
universe in a world it was just awesome
probably the moment at video village
when he was standing there and we were
like [ __ ] how do we get him to step down
from there
no no no obviously oh that was awesome
and he was great great instincts I would
say um nothing
during the shooting it's um the first
rehearsals and read-throughs and prep
were the moments I remember because you
cast everyone you try to get the best
actor for the part obviously and these
were guys all were undeniable and how
they own their role but it's always in a
vacuum and and a show really works not
on any one character but in the
relationships between them just the
chemistry and you just you never know if
the chemistry is gonna work and
sometimes it just doesn't and so when
these guys got together when he got
together with Shue when all the actors
when all the seven were together when
Carl and Jack were together and you
could see their energy is butcherin
Hughie and you just saw it they become
greater than the sum of their parts like
they're just it's it's all the energy
bouncing off each other and creating a
new thing that was really exciting
because when you realize that you have
that you as a showrunner who's done this
a couple times when you see what when
you have that you're like oh thank god
that's gonna work right so yeah that I
could ask a million other questions
she's gonna kill me if I do so I'm just
gonna
everyone at Amazon was gonna say thank
you for giving yeah I mean it seriously
to everyone watching I loved what I've
seen of this show I'm genuinely so
excited you guys got a second season and
seriously congratulations I can't wait
to finish it I hope it's a massive hit
thank you